hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal wann
und willkommen zu dieser ganz speziellen
folge wie schmeckt komposition heute
machen wir die ba rosi mauerbau sie also
die teigtaschen die meister shifu
benutzt um den panda-bären computer
zulegen
wer konnte man dann nicht gesehen hat
und ich glaube eigentlich das kann
niemand sein dann kommt man als so ein
schöner film es geht darum dass der
pandabär po 1 nudelsuppen macher ist
also sein vater seine ente und die macht
heidel suppen und pro träumt aber davon
kein nudelsuppen macher zu sein sondern
ein komfort meister sowie die kuriosen 5
furiosen fünf teils crane monkey
menschen während der auswahl zeremonie
vielen drachenkrieger wird auf einmal
pro ausgewählt zu jeder überraschung
denn es ist ein dicker panda und niemand
würde ihm zutrauen dass er ein computer
sein kann
aber meister shifu hat schnell gemerkt
dass er ihnen wird essen kriegen kann
und deswegen machen wir die bällchen
zeigt welche meister shifu punkt geben
möchte mannschaft mit den krippen also
los geht's
[Musik]
ich habe gerade gesehen dass dieser film
aus 2008 ist das war vor zehn jahren und
die musik ist von hans zimmer machte was
immer die musik bekommen fu panda
konnten die pause bestehen aus zwei
teilen einmal dem teig und der füllung
und bei der füllung habe ich mir sehr
viele gedanken drüber gemacht auf welche
füllung der pandabär po stehen würde
originale bau sie bestehen nämlich aus
schweinefleisch und ich glaube nicht
dass ein panda gerne schweinefleisch ist
besonders weil da die tiere so
untereinander leben und alle miteinander
sprechen es wäre komisch wenn die bau
sie mit schweinefleisch ja und weil pro
ein dicker fetter panda ist dann eine
zutat auf jeden fall nicht fehlen bambus
dann hatte ich noch dass hier ein
richtig witziges kirchen bin und
chinakohl sein packe ein bisschen
schnittlauch darf auch nicht fehlen
und noch etwas asiatisches pak choi und
ein bisschen sexy mio und dann ist die
sache geritzt so zuerst müssen wir alles
klein schneiden dafür brauchen wir ein
scharfes asiatisches messer da sind
asiatische schriftzeichen drauf deshalb
ist es scharf ich sollte mich mit meinem
messer spielen
das liefert was fehlt jetzt noch eine
epische schneide szene
[Musik]
jetzt wo wir unsere füllung klein
gehackt haben machen wir uns an den teig
ich hab keine ahnung warum ich die ganze
zeit kommt von bewegungen mache ich habe
mir vorher noch mal den film angeguckt
der liegt einfach dazu ein brauchen wir
500 gramm mehl was ihr von 3 an
gefangenen mehr packungen nehmen könnte
dann brauchen wir noch drei 150
milliliter von der quelle des lebens
wasser ach so dass nur lauwarm sein eine
prise zucker einen teelöffel salz und
ein esslöffel öl und am allerwichtigsten
eine packung trockenhefe und jetzt
machen wir den browser teig also baby
gibt mir mehr von dem was sie lieben es
wenn sie also welchen europa wie bitte
gib mir mehr von dem was du dumpings
nennst bitte gib mir chinesische
dumpings und bowser welchen nutzen zu
vergessen was war im markt eine schale
denn wir müssen alle zutaten miteinander
vermengt gut geraten sehr gut irland
dazu ich habe schon abgewogen wird ihr
klar wird gramm mehl 3
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir unser wasser und trinkt
einen großen schluck hinweg jetzt werden
unser lauwarmes wasser die trockenhefe
und eine prise zucker damit die hefe
sich so richtig freude und sagte ja ich
aktiviere mich denn hier und jetzt würde
das alles schön verrührt ich lasse es
gebe wasser kurz an der seite stehen und
mache jetzt seien es in unser mehl rein
und ich vergessen ein esslöffel noch
reinmachen
unsere hier bewirkt unbedingt in den
mail zeigen deswegen kippen wir denn
jetzt da rein natürlich mit einer
epischen stromaufnahme
[Musik]
so episch
und jetzt müssen wir die zutaten ganz
enges miteinander verrühren com fucile
und aber gerade auch dass die
verbraucher sieht irgendwie einfach so
stinkt und pala pizzateig ist mehl salz
warmes wasser hefe dass es einfach ein
ganz normaler hilfe zeige ich dachte das
ist jetzt so super special asiatisch
aber nö ist einfach nur hier führt ein
umbau ist das ein schöner teil
[Musik]
nein
und das ist jetzt fertig muss jetzt für
eine stunde ruhen und in der zeit
kümmern wir uns weiter um die verloren
gute nacht geht eigentlich super einfach
wie parken was von unserem china coal in
die schüssel
ja ich mache jetzt mal so die hälfte
rein dann natürlich unser pak choi den
ich ein bisschen groß geschnitten habe
und natürlich unser schnittlauch und
natürlich alles miteinander verhöre
bisschen komisch islam aufnahmen sind
vielleicht nicht die beste technik um
kleine sachen zu schneiden aber unsere
wichtigste zutat bambus darf natürlich
nicht fehlen wird sagen man nimmt immer
ein bisschen bambus und schneidet den
klein- oder kann mich gar nicht mehr
erinnern meine mutter hat immer mussten
kommen verwendet aber irgendwie seit ich
nicht mehr zu hause wohnen
hmm lecker rambus das ist gut klein
geschnitten körper muss aber da liegt
auch einfach noch nichts
lecker also dass ich jetzt das erste mal
seit langem wieder aus als ob ich
wirklich kochen würde die meisten
rezepte die ich mache sind einfach so
hier wir machen gewinn und dann packen
wir sehen ein parcours ein und jetzt
wird alles gewürzt mit einem guten
schuss sojasauce ich habe keine rezepte
angaben deswegen macht das einfach
draußen baustellen aber wenn nicht
vielleicht gut bin schreibe ich einfach
das rezept unten in die beschreibung wo
es das lux gehört braucht man da jetzt
eigentlich seid wenn man sojasauce nimmt
dann ist er schon
ich bin auch ich nicht glaube ich mache
es sei aber ein bisschen gemüsebrühe
kann ich habe einfach mal so darüber
streuen und wieder mal lebensmittel
rassismus weil sie aus asien kommt denke
ich dass man ein bisschen scharf gemacht
aber nur ein paar flocken und das ist
unsere füllung für die frau sie gar
nicht mehr so scheiße aus ich habe schon
mal eine fahne mit wasser auf den herd
gestellt weil wir die bei rosi nicht
kochen werden oder braten sondern dampf
gase und ihr kennt mich wenn es lässt
sich nicht lumpen ich habe extra einen
dampfgarer gejammer mir dass er
natürlich in meinem dampfgarer können
wir das gerne machen
das prinzip ist eigentlich ganz einfach
man erhitzt wasser sodass es dampft aber
nicht so wirklich kocht dann stellt man
dieses teil obendrauf und durch die
löcher unten kann der dampf durch gehen
und dann werden die halt dampf gegart
die pause ich sag das bestimmt fall
schon jetzt regen sich ganz eigentliche
leute auf das heißt bau- oder für mich
sind es pause ok und unser teig ist
größer geworden
ungefähr doppelt so groß natürlich ist
es schön umso länger herum kann umso
größer wird das flieger wir haben aber
hier keine zeit sie schmeckt es ein
lebendiges schnelles verfahren deswegen
machen wir weiter
ich habe wieder meinen fuß per rad
verloren ich muss sie zurück kriegen
also sich jetzt aus wie chefkoch einmal
pause klar kriegen wie gut ich habe mir
viele videos dazu angeschaut wie man
denn jetzt diesen browser zeigt wie man
den knetet heute und zusammenfaltet das
ist sehr schwer aber wenn es hinkriegen
ich kann den tanz nicht wirklich aber es
sieht ganz gut aus sie nehmen uns jetzt
ein bisschen von unserem teig und
freundin mal so zu einer kugel
es ist eine schöne kugel jetzt nehme ich
mir ein nudelholz und
suche das zu einem dünnen fladen
auszurollen das ist wie pizzateig ich
kenne keinen unterschied war am rand
muss unser tag dünner sein als in der
mitte das ist bei der fall technik sehr
sich die bau sie sind übrigens ein
traditionelles chinesisches gericht was
man auch zum frühstück isst und was in
verschiedenen variationen kommen kann du
kannst das mit süßer basteln oder mit
vegetarisch live wie du magst so jemand
meinen großen löffel und das kommt jetzt
auf unseren teil möchte nicht zuviel
damit wir noch falten können
um an das sieht nicht gut aus wir legen
das jetzt hoch und falten
ich habe gelesen dass dauert bis man die
technik drauf hat vielfalt wird einfach
immer so ein knick und legen ihnen
diesen knick über die falten sie können
mich mal so schlecht auf die mütze
knicken und überlegen oh mein gott oh
mein gott da kommt keine füllung raus
der sieht cool aus ich bin naturtalent
na klar sie dann noch nicht perfekt aus
aber schaut euch das mal an
ich versuch's mal mit backpapier das ist
nämlich das gute vorsichtsmaßnahme das
gut aus und so kommt dann unseren
dampfgarer und jetzt mache ich noch ein
paar weitere in epischer aufnahme viel
spaß
[Musik]
schaut mal wie gut es aussieht ich hab
jetzt verschiedene größte gemacht
verschiedene decken
ich bin gespannt wie werden wir jetzt
auch unseren dampfgarer packen mit dem
deckel drauf für 20 minuten und dann
werden wir schauen was daraus geworden
ist
20 minuten sind vergangen und wir holen
unsere pause pauli wo sie sich
vorsichtig vorsichtig okay wir schneiden
im aufruhr ja doch der sieht wunderschön
aus mein gott es gerade richtig das
wasser im mund zusammen nun stellen wir
uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken die
bei sie auskomme panda mit ganz viel
bambus weil po 1
honda ist das ist so lecker man schmeckt
irgendwie des bambus konsistenz ist geil
dieser kohl dieses paket lauf alles
perfekt einfach wie gesagt ich werde das
rezept unten infobox packen
ich hab's mir selber ausgedacht deswegen
schaue ich noch mal wie viel die
ungefähr von einem verwendet haben und
wenn euch das video gefallen hat daumen
nach oben und kann abonnieren dann
verpasst ihr kein neues wie schmeckt der
fresh com
das ist folgt dann